ờ ờ
bài câu chấm đoàn không ạ
không bị bắt đầu đề cốt lên
Ừ nhưng mà nói cho hôm nay vẫn là một
buổi nhẹ nhàng đúng không
Hôm nay chấm + chữa đồ án
các nhóm
có thắc mắc
thì có thể
hỏi trực tiếp
bây giờ mình
nhục luôn à
à à
có phải vài nhóm cũng thay đổi mới mới
cập nhật
Ừ để xem Bây giờ tôi ngồi lát Xem Việt
Nam
Cập nhật này
không ạ
lượt từng nhóm nhé
hôm nay thì tôi sẽ không đánh giá về ở
tài liệu nữa có nhờ tài liệu có vài nhóm
mình xong rồi đúng
Ừ tôi sẽ đánh giá về về cốt Tôi sẽ góp ý
ở trong đấy còn tài liệu thì coi như là
thành nhóm xong rồi tôi sẽ bỏ qua
bộ tất cả không ai đi đánh giá Lại Từ
Đầu
đầu
tiên là tài liệu không biết ở nhóm này
a nhớ mày nhờ có tài liệu rồi nói
À hôm trước mới cập nhật à 24 tháng 6
ở ngã tư là hôm trước ăn cập nhật rồi
rồi chấm rồi chưa bổ sung thêm gì cả kê
như mình sẽ kiểm tra cái cốt nhá
cho xem mặt Source code của ông ấy anh
sẽ như thế nào
chỉ cần Zalo có khá nhiều không ạ Ừ
ở chùa gì cả
rồi Chưa cần nói lời chưa có gì cả
Tràm thêm sửa xóa gì cả
Ừ bạn em ạ Kệ bạn làm view Phan lên
trước tôi
Ừ tôi không đánh giá về mình cái cốt
anh ở bên giao diện lắm mà tôi sẽ để ý
nhiều Bác em rồi xử lý hơn
Chị xem thử xem à Cố Thử ở bên
cho tôi bây giờ
thử xem
ạ
ừ ừ
bạn múa lân
a phone number
ở chỗ này cũng được lại có khách
siết đình cũng chẳng có gì mấy đúng
không
ở đó xem máy bay nè
a Talent
thơ Nguyễn chơi gì mấy nhóc
ừ ừ
ở
ngoài đây file có sẵn rồi nó
hôm nay ngồi chấm kiểm tra đồ ăn mà
nay này là buổi gần như là buổi tôi chấm
và bé ông hoàn toàn có thắc mắc gì tâm
sự gì hay gì đó thì hôm nay o này mà xem
mà chữa đừng nhóm mình yêu xem chưa nó
cũng không nó cũng hơi bị tẩy nhạc nó
cũng chẳng có cái gì cả anh em một buổi
giao lưu theo kiểu là là kiểu cuối tuần
thì thư giãn một tí nhiều hơn chứ không
Không mang đến chất nặng nề gì cả bởi vì
mấy hôm trước tôi cốt ví dụ điển hình
ngay hôm qua là Cốt đã căng thẳng rồi
đúng ạ thì chính tôi cũng không muốn nó
nặng nề Tôi muốn nó rất là thoải mái
hay bị xóa rồi Phải đợi tí thôi xem lại
à Scott Fox
nhóm 2 như bò sát ở mỗi nhóm 2 rồi vậy
Gửi tao xóa luôn cái đường link
đừng có tạo này đã Okay tiếp nhóm 3A
em xóa đi
ờ ờ
led đang lỗi
lại chưa ừ ừ
Khi nào xem thử Source code của người
driver sợ của driver ở đây nhỉ
Vì
sao là tên nó driver
ăn thiếu dầu cá ở đây trong khó chịu ơi
em hết có và paste gram luôn xịn
ừ ừ
khoa học phí công
à Anh nhầm cái
tội lỗi tôi
a beat me the weather
chị xem nhé
để xem cốt này hi vọng là mấy ông không
cho là chiều thay làm thế người khác ăn
cắp ý tưởng ăn cắp cốt của em
em không có chậm lắm đúng không
các bạn vẫn mới đang chỉ cho chung là
mau à
ở đâu mà mới được quay thôi Chưa gì cả Ở
đây Pha này có về được à
tp này này
ở đâu
season 7 lưu lại trong sân không dùng
hours season nóng lạnh Uh cho nó cơ bản
ông ạ
Ừ rồi chia cho cậu level nhảy ra Chiều
nhai
Ừ cũng được được
tên vietjack
ở độ cao xơ blog của shop cũng khó kêu
số like
để đăng nhập vào nhau sao hôm qua ông mà
xem cốt của tôi Không phải Xóa các bạn
sao rồi gấp
anh em Ông ông sẽ giàu thay mới Các bạn
truyền hình nhau chứ vì hôm qua làm được
đấy làm nhiệm vụ kia rồi ạ
ở những tài khoản khác mình chưa biết
cập nhật Chưa
Cứ ngồi cầm tao để tao biết rồi chị
I am i này
a ghi mấy
a
student Để thử xem tốt lành nha
em đừng cho là gì
cho trẻ listing áo mới chị đang ỉa
viewers cũng chưa có
hiển thị ra thêm sửa xóa một cái gì cả
thì phải
anh không nhỉ
xe tải mất công tơ hai con
Em sắp Attack mình như làm được cái vụ
đấy phải đi
em nhớ không làm như là sắp itech nó có
cho kiểu bấm vào file nào thì chị luôn
phải đấy em nhé
được
trực tiếp nhằm tiếp theo
Ý mình nói mày chưa có gì dính dáng à
tôi cũng chẳng không Nó đánh giá thì
mình không ghi lại trong ngày đúng không
ạ Chả có gì cả à
cả nhóm tiếp theo à
có mấy nhóm chậm tiến độ hai nhanh tiến
độ thì kệ tôi không quan tâm vấn đề lấy
lắm
mỗi nhóm có một cái việc gì đó hai cái
từ hướng tôi không quan tâm lắm nhóm nào
làm thì tôi đánh giá Nói chung nó nói
chung vào kiểu mình
Ừ mình không giục làm gì cả Mình cũng
chẳng gọi buồn mà cái gì cả đúng gọn Cứ
thoải mái thôi nếu hiểu cho không là mày
thôi
Ông Hà ông nghe lại ngồi bảo dùng ghét
cô đấy Hôm nay tôi dùng hết cốt kết hợp
của cả mát ơi bấm khó chịu với ai chưa
quen hết các phím tắt gỡ rồi mình phim
bát của vé cốc thì tao biết một vai gáy
Nếu mà cái hợp việc súng mát bấm rau má
trong phím tắt người khác nữa rồi
dùng sự khó chịu càng thêm lý do nữa là
thứ nhất là mình sẽ Google Maps thứ hai
là sẽ Thực ra nếu mà để nói thật là tôi
rất thích về các hệ sinh thái khá phổ
làm rất là ổn với cái hệ sinh thái ở một
khoảng nào đó là kiểu về điện thoại máy
tính bảng
laptop kết hợp với cả màn hình chẳng hạn
đấy đúng ạ xong rồi cả à
ở những cánh đồng hồ nóng lạnh với hệ
sinh thái rất tốt nhưng nếu mà thực sự
thích thì tôi thích hệ sinh thái của
thằng Huawei hơn Và thậm chí thằng
Google hơn
cho tôi bây giờ để nói ăn TF bồ thì cũng
đúng giống như mày không thấy rồi nhưng
mà Gần đây tôi không phải là tôi Cậu đến
nỗi bảo thủ đến thế Tôi vẫn công nhận
được cái gì nó hai cái dụ là tôi cũng
định là sang năm thì tôi sẽ sẽ dành tiền
để mua con iPhone 13 Mini về bản chất là
tôi thích dùng hai hệ điều hành hoặc
nhiều hệ điều hành cùng một lúc để mà
kiểu mình sẽ có tăng thêm cái trải
nghiệm cũng như là kiểu sẽ so sánh được
cả xem thằng nào nó có mạng điểm nào tôi
rất thích kiểu Huế Hồi trước của tôi đã
dùng hai con điện thoại cùng lúc một một
con iPhone 1 con Nokia nhưng mà nhưng mà
cậu Hồi đấy cầu
dùng iPhone cũ Hòa xong rồi nâng nâng à
chức năng hệ điều hành lên à Xong rồi tự
nhiên sập luôn máy rồi mang vào hàng thì
nó kêu không may Hồi đấy còn bảo hành
xong rồi nó nó còn tặng Nguyên lại còn
mấy mới ạ Tôi thấy còn là biểu diễn quá
bán lại lấy luôn đây rồi đấy ạ cho nhân
vào sang năm thì tôi sẽ thích cậu mua
con iPhone 13 mini bởi vì ạ Nó rất là
nhỏ gọn Tôi thích cái sự nhỏ gọn thế nói
chị tôi ở trong Hồi mà tôi ấn tượng xấu
nhất là cái hồi mà ngay từ hồi mà ra con
iPhone 6 Plus của to chưa không hở thì
các bạn nữ thì cái đấy Cho tôi thấy cậu
con trai rồi để tụi để trong túi quần
như con to ấy chịu
á Vừa nãy còn đầu tiên điện thoại to
trong
như thế phải cho hơi mất cảm tình ái
À mà thôi lại xong dài không vợ cái thì
đoạn này thì mới tôi nghĩa mấy ông bài
làm bài ca chúng tôi
đồng hồ cũng đi ở season cũng như lại
kiểu à Ông trách này ổn mà làm từ cái ổ
này xong rồi Beats fake góc này ổn nhưng
mà Đấy nhược điểm đó bạn đấy lại
à À đây Mày tưởng đặt tên nó trót được
không phải kiểu như này như thế này thì
cũng thôi Thực ra tôi không thích kiểu
Để như này để Adidas rồi để Adidas của
mình nó dễ bị à dễ bị hiểu về sau không
hiểu chóp Đây đang là cái gì lắm là đã
bấm vào nó sẽ nhảy sang bên này Nhưng mà
anh kiểu ngay nếu không hiểu cho
a cho cái
constant-cost Xin thì mình sẽ nên để nó
ở trong không về để đây nhá sẽ để trong
thằng như này ok chưa ạ Mình sẽ thường
là cho nó 1 cái là kiểu
Vì sao đây báo lỗi này cái này vốn có sử
dụng không nhỉ
Hay phết mà cả pháp nick tùy thôi thường
để file vết của ngày ấy tôi thử format
code của ông này lại thì mình ông sẽ
thấy da sẽ khác những cái gì mai có cốt
để tôi chậm nó mày ông nha ấy khi li
format lại mà ông thấy em nó sẽ luôn
cách ra một cái mặc định cách một cái ra
như này Thứ hai là mấy ông thấy dùng
tp-store nó sẽ gợi ý có những cái ở đây
như cái bát khi không không dùng nữa
Đừng gọi đấy Cái này đang lúc đầu như
thế nào Cái này đang kiểu là
ở Barcelona rồi
ừ ừ
anh nhìn cốc cho đoạn này thì ra hơi bị
đau mắt Nếu mà mày không thấy thực sự
khó chịu là thực vị tính thì được là cái
đoạn này nó hơi bị đau mắt là bạn này nó
hiểu cho cái đoạn này thì như hôm qua
tôi tạo cái hàm hấp Ơ bạn này có thể
tham khảo là là mình sẽ lấy lấy rô ra rẽ
chẳng hạn thế
chị sẽ tạo hay Bolero hay cái gì đó thì
nó đỡ khó chịu hơn kiểu như em không ạ
Viết cái đoạn này cách ra ạ Bạn không có
khách cho mà Bạn này cần chỉnh lại về
Cái được và
cái kiểu format lại cốt cho dùng ghế cô
không cũng lười đi format luôn đấy thiếu
nhiều Cách thứ thứ Cái này dùng hàm này
cũng được bản chất là thằng level có sẵn
ghế hàm để mà hát rồi ông thể dục rồi
đấy tiếp theo là
season flash
ý kiến ngay ghi thêm cái A đi thêm cái
me ship vào trong cài A Reason that A em
chỉ cần dùng with đoạn này được còn đỡ
phải dài dòng Dùng kế hàng ít như thế
này nó sẽ tương đương với system flash
hiểu không Đỡ cần phải làm gì cậu làm
dạo này
Ừ nó cầu kỳ kết hợp việc là là cái này
thật ra lại kiểu bạn để biết biết thì
mới dùng cái này chỉ có bạn này nó ngắn
hơn rồi Như này Cản Thế à
ạ Bạn ấy biết thì bạn thấy làm như thế
này nhưng mà người mà mở kiểu
cầu dạng là kotler chưa quen mình sẽ
thấy đoạn này kiểu trong nó sẽ cho hiểu
tại sao đúng không ạ
thực hiện đặt tên là tôi mất
Ừ cũng được
Ừ nhưng mà lên cái này thì ra tùy thường
à thường là tên Hà thì sẽ là là thử động
từ còn tên biến thì thực ra là ở ít kiểu
động từ âm thường của danh từ nhiều hơn
không không tôi lần đầu dọn thấy hiểu
động từ gửi ngay
thôi chả tôi sẽ tham khảo tuổi chìm với
ông tham khảo được tôi đi spa đây lấy
kiểu như này thì nó sẽ nên lập tên trong
trường hợp này nó sẽ là kiểu ở It's new
rằng ạ It's a restore nhặn nghĩa là mới
đăng mới đăng ký để mà em chỉ là mình sẽ
gửi mail Gửi mail cho
người mail để mà thông báo đăng ký nhé
Hiểu Cho Anh
Ừ
dạo này nó bị buồn cười ta cái là đoạn
này không phải kiểm tra trước thì ông
sếp trông ngày Ông đăng ký mới trông
điều hướng quay trở lại bà lỗi đúng ạ
không nên có cái đoạn này phải đầy xuống
dưới
ở đây Phone này trong sự ngày tôi vào
bảo thì để lấy được cái đi Follow này nó
sẽ là Seo như thế này để lấy vợ đây
Em tải cái hàm này cũng lên đẩy trong
cái Happy là tốt ngoại từ như hôm qua
tôi làm Thí sinh miss sport Ok có thấy
cốt ông này cũng vẻ ổn nhưng sao hôm nay
hi vọng vì ngon để mà xem cái chưa sửa
mà thể tham khảo thêm
em Treo như về tôi từng nói mấy ông về
cái level best practice
nhiều không ạ Mà ông cha Giờ này có thể
như tôi bảo là có khác phiên bản tiếng
Việt luôn chỉ cho mấy ông nhớ Nhưng mà
thực ra là thế bản tiếng Việt này nó vẫn
lên để đọc vẫn đọc được mọi việc nó có
thêm một vài chi tiết nhỏ mà trong cái
bản chính không có cơ tôi đọc rồi đọc
hai bạn và cả tiếng Anh và tiếng Việt
Tôi không biết ngôn ngữ khác là nó ngôn
ngữ khác thông cả nếu mà
Thì chỉ theo quy tắc chung Thì ra là cái
đấy không phải của mỗi lao nữa mà của pp
Nói chung ấy thì Ừ cái A cái coastal cái
Hạ Hằng số nó sẽ viết hoa mọi chữ cái
chứ không phải viết hoa bộ chữ cái đầu
như thế này để ông ấy sửa lại và cái này
nó sẽ giống như là tôi nếu mà tôi đang
dùng cái à
ở đây đâu sẽ thấy là nó sẽ cảnh báo đây
là nên nên còn thêm cả chỗ dạng là nên
có kiểu là nó là thêm cái kiểu dạng Asus
tức là mặc định nếu mà không ghi gì mà
sẽ public nhưng mà cho mình nên ghi cụ
thể hơn thì chợ mà nên xóa xoay chú
thích đoạn này nữa thử chứ
chấm nhóm mày kỹ quá kia là anh cứ bởi
móc em
Anh kể tiếp nha à
ở đài grab
Em có phải em ở cơm nhà hôm trước
I stay và tôi quê hương
mã số thẻ
3dp nhóm này mới chấm hôm trước cũng
chưa có gì mấy chưa có gì cả t hiệu khác
xem à
à à
bằng đây cả
có 1 cái đăng kýđăng nhập
em heo này hôm đấy
Ừ ok chưa có gì cho mấy tạ anh em ơi
Anh hello ok chưa có thì có gì đây ta
vị trí
a Vietnamese mới cập nhật hôm qua
một vài bếp và bếp viết sai chính tả
đúng không varese
anh sạc cái điện dân được mấy cái vụ đó
ô ồ sao nhiều cô đấy xem à
mục nữa không thì về sau nhất là
Ừ thế là đôi khi không phải là nhiều
người khuấy nước à Nhiều người quy ước
là cứ mỗi controller là cái gắn liền một
bảng ra không nên như thế bởi vì nếu thể
đi ỉa
tôi thường hay
Ừ cái bản chất cân thiếu đâu đấy nó sẽ
là chim ạ Chị Skinny controller phát mua
đồ tất cả mua đồ sẽ chữa rất nhiều dự
điện chứa nhiều câu truy vấn trong đấy
còn gần như ở bên các chữ L cốt là nó
làm theo cầu là
theo số lít tất cả single single Action
nghĩa lắm cái kiểu có một mục đích duy
nhất trong câu trả lời thôi kệ là nó
không nên chưa quá nhiều lôgic ở trong
control cũng như là kiểu có khóa nhiều
axit như mấy thớt ở trong container phải
có thể nó tách xa khỏi những con cho nó
khác
em chẳng hạn thế
a và có thể tách ra hẳn thứ mục của Bến
admin riêng Hòa bên giao riêng cũng là
một ví dụ chỉ nói Ví dụ nếu có đầy đủ
tính năng thêm sửa xóa ấy đúng là nằm
trong container từ liên quan đến bản
thật nhưng có những cái tính năng điển
hình giống như à Bây giờ giả sử Tôi làm
thì năng thống kê liên quan rất bún bảng
thì ông sẽ bớt cần thơ nè đúng hoặc khi
cần như thì nghe cái câu đấy đủ biết đâu
phải tách hẳn lên cho riêng nó kèo
controller tên là à Thống kê được ạ sử
thế đúng ạ thì rõ ràng là
đó là về sau của ông sẽ có rất nhiều con
trả lời ở đây nó liên quan đến các tính
năng đúng ạ thì thì ông phải chia nhỏ
làm thư mục nữa thì nó hợp lý hơn chứ về
sau ông hiển thị ra đây tận 30 40
à Còn nếu mà ông làm một dự án lớn ở
công ty lớn thì nó còn chưa còn to nữa
thì mới ông chết à ạ nhìn sẽ bị choáng
không ạ nhiều thư mục cũng được nhưng
mỗi thư mục rồi có các thứ thứ nó hợp lý
hơn đúng ạ và sẽ chia hợp lý hơn và cái
file của ông sẽ không bị dày cốt quá
Ừ ok chưa
thêm vài khuya nữa đúng
đoạn này nếu mà thật sự người chính bản
thân mình tôi tin à chính bản thân anh
em và tôi cũng đi có cốt về mấy cái đoạn
này thường là nên chú thích thêm cái
đoạn một cái rất là hay một cái rất hay
nó như thế này ví dụ Giả sử cái không
nhìn thấy biết ngay là lấy nhá olo của
Karen ghét Euro parent
khi phát nặng Lazio chẳng hạn ngay Đúng
rồi Thương ơi có phải đầu tiên được chứ
Lâu gì không ạ Được kiểu dạng thật sự
ngay ra xử ngay không ạ thì mình giả sử
mình đấy một cái gì đó
Ừ thì lấy có từ đây ngon có một cái ra
hay thì cho mình anh em gì mà hiểu đem
về sau thì xem lại và bây giờ sửa cái gì
đó bị người khác hiểu được cả ngày nghĩ
cái loại này đâu ra bận trả nợ thế Để
cái sau thể xem bởi vì a Hãy nên nhớ là
cái câu hỏi trả lời mấy câu trả lời thế
này nó ngoài việc là nó trả lời nó không
thấy sau có thể chỉnh câu trả lời của
Chính nó để mà sao phù hợp cái gì đó nữa
thì anh em đôi khi ở thấy cái đoạn này
về sau không ổn nữa ạ có thể xem trực
tiếp cái link cũ để mà sửa thì nó sẽ
thường ai kiểu ngay công ty công ty tôi
đúng kiểu làm ngay sẽ ngày đó chú thích
đoạn như này kèm theo bà mình sẽ chú
thích thêm cái gì đó ví dụ ghét cô đơn
thường là tôi thường cách 2 một cái đấy
chứ không ai thấy ghét cô đơn tab lại
đái cả nhà không cần được giữ lại cái
chữ hay soi kết hợp với ai ta sẽ hiểu
được cả thì tại sao mình có cái đoạn này
sinh ra phải trả nợ thế còn nếu mà ông
không muốn có thêm Vậy là chú thích này
cũng sẽ phải tạo một cái biến khu lưng
bát nghe đi
cô gái à
ở đây sẽ your part II
ở đó thì sẽ Vừa dễ hiểu là cái đoạn này
nó sẽ cho đoạn này đúng không và cái
biến này như này Ok chưa
Em Thấy thấy việc ở tôi đang có hỗ trợ
mình không có việc là cải thiện dần được
và cốt có thử không không ạ ạ
Ừ cái tôi chấm cốt cho bé uống có thử
khi à
Thì cũng phải là tên biến dễ hiểu đúng
không Chứ cái này thì tôi hiểu nhưng mà
có thể người khác có thể chưa hiểu cái
hàng này tác dụng gì được ạ đúng ạ
Em
hãy làm sao cho mà Để về sau mình à khi
mình đọc lại cốt của mình Mị phải không
cần phải dùng trí nhớ nhiều mà mình cũng
hình dung được bởi nhiều ông hay quên
lắm nói thẳng À không biết mày ông ở như
thế nào nhưng tôi thì tôi nhớ cốt của
tôi đã có gì thật còn mấy ông thì chưa
chắc là đã nhiều được là mình đã có gì
đâu đấy ông nhìn đoạn này có hiểu không
hiểu đoạn đấy Tại sao cũng như thế không
ạ thì ông lại đang cố nhớ về lôgic Hồi
đấy chứ không phải là ông nhìn vào để
ông hiểu được lôgic nữa chứ đoạn này ông
đang Cốt nó lôgic rất là rối nên thấy
không phải cố nhớ Tại sao mình tại sao
mình cốt như thế chứ không phải là Đọc
cốt để hiểu được đúng ạ Hai cái phân
biệt Nếu hiểu lý do hai cái phân biệt rõ
ràng không ạ một cái là cốt dễ hiểu nên
đọc cái hiểu luôn và một cái là mình còn
chẳng nhớ Đoạn này đoạn này rất khó hiểu
Nhưng mình phải cố nhớ sẽ Tại sao mình
có này Ừ thế thì người khác nhìn vào cốt
của ông làm sao mà biết được đúng không
ạ Thế nên là không không chơi cờ đấy
được không ạ
anh nói chung à cốt của một Junior thì
chú thích nhiều
Ừ nó nó nhưng mà chứ thích không đúng
chỗ và nó cũng hơi già có thể thử còn
cốt của sieu và Master thì sẽ ít tùy
thích chú thích cần nhiều chỉ có mấy
kiểu như này Vân ít vài cái cảnh báo
thôi thì có thôi còn vài cái có một cái
ra 2 nếu không nếu để ý kĩ nữa nó có
khái niệm ở trên
pistone nó cũng gợi ý cho mấy ông đó là
đu đủ trí này đó sẽ tự động bôi cho ông
ngay tôi thương ai kéo nhưng lòng ngay
cả này Đấy nếu thấy cái cái này là do
tôi để màu nó thành kiểu như này chứ mày
không có đôi khi nó cũng ra màu như này
đâu đấy thì thường như hai sau đó thì về
sau ông chỉ cần odoo như thế này xấu sẽ
Peter theo mỗi Long trở lại Ý của tôi là
chọn theo kiểu Editor cơ à Xong rồi mặc
định là Long như thế này Sao lại thì sẽ
là tôi đấy Xong rồi nó sẽ liệt kê toàn
bộ các dudu những cái mà
ý là cần phải làm cần phải sửa cần phải
xem lại ở đấy
em có heo bị rất nhiều lúc mình xin nốt
lại trong trứng cút của mình theo cái gì
thế
sau đó thêm một cái nữa mà định mà Mấy
ông chưa biết không ạ Có thể cho biết
gì đấy
cho bé ông nhiều lắm tôi không nó không
ghi lại ở trong khác tác à Hay thồ Nói
chung là ông nào nhớ được thì nhớ tôi
cũng không Thiệt cũng không nhớ hết được
tất cả các mẹo để tôi chia sẻ cùng đồng
loạt cùng lúc
với ông biết ở Lúc nào hay đúng vậy thôi
không ạ
các hợp chất object có người có vẻ hơi
lại sẽ thức có trách
À hôm trước anh Tráng chỉ có bạn này thì
dễ hơn đúng không ạ Có thể phó mắt thằng
luôn khung carbon
ờ ờ ông để nó là cast là cass là tham
trăm là đất hay mày cái gì đói sao ông
sẽ gọi đến và pho mát nó dễ hơn thay vì
phải ta thêm một lần nữa
a spa khẩu âm Trần Hạ
ừ ừ
à à Lưu vậy trong thư mục gì à nghe
xuống cũng được Ok bin
ạ sau giống này mới đấy không ạ Ok cũng
được cũng được
ở cái đoạn này tôi thấy là nhiều Nhiều
lúc ông trong một vài trường hợp ông
truyền về vai trò là new như thế này
không cần không cần lắm mà mình sẽ để
mặc định là không cần điền đoạn thay thổ
không cần truyền thái tổ cũng được ở bên
hạ view là được giống như đó Thử Ví dụ
nhé Đây là
Xin chào đến Rio thấy truyền cái nha bắt
buộc phải chuyển hai hồ nên mới thế
thế này cái này nên ghi lại lấy riêng
cái này thì lên lấy từ confix và lấy và
con thích áp và trong con huyết áp thì
nó sẽ mặc định có thêm nêm và nó lấy từ
ác nên và ăn nêm thì mình sẽ lấy từ nv
về sau mình chỉ cần sửa sẽ phải nv vào
App lên ở đây thôi Thì mình sẽ lấy được
chúng mình không nên hot cốt Cường ai để
khuyên của tôi như thế
thấy thua máy bay rồi
thay đồ rồi đại khái Nếu mà Mấy ông cần
truyền kỳ bắt buộc phải truyền đi Ở đây
đây đây đây
thì ông ạ
nó ở nhà
ở Châu Á
access a
à à
a cho Thái Tổ bộ phim xe cẩu có Thái Tổ
nhớ ai à xe khách hàng ngày được về à
có ai
anh xô ngồi em reset xong
Ừ xong hả
trở lại như này
em chẳng hạn như và thường người ta sẽ
cho kiểu cho nó hẳn xuống dòng ngay cho
nó kiểu gì nó tường minh đi
ở đó về chưa
Nha được
thích kiểu ngay tới sửa cốt được cho mấy
ông rồi Ông tiện
ở đoạn này So sánh rồi nha
Ừ cũng được
gì tự nhiên nói chuyện lên được hiểu là
chỗ ấy đúng không có nhiều cá ai khó
chịu vãi cái gì chửi Lệ ở chỗ ấy
á nhon
a cho level
anh alo Tải Lego này không đúng rồi biết
này không dùng thật level khai báo đây
mà cái Lego này sai rồi
anh
không thấy bạn này nó đang cảnh báo thấy
không test ôm vừa có lợi để mày đấy Ông
làm cái sai rồi
đỏ lòm bao nhiêu thứ thế nào
Ừ ông ấy đang khai báo ở trong
không bao giờ Vision là pp 7.4 ở đâu về
với Đúng rồi Tôi đang để ha cốc luôn
cảnh báo
a ceiling đơn giản ngắn gọn
Anh An Ninh Lâm bầu này
sự thực là tôi không khuyên không nên
dùng Faker ở trong trường hợp với cái
giá kiểu như thế này mà mình lên cho gửi
giá Dạo này nó sẽ bị số mà ông không
thích thì ông hẳn van roon ABS có sẵn
của hoa cà nó có cái French của nó là
phạm vi từ bao nhiêu bao nhiêu nó sẽ ổn
hơn hai kiểu ngay
Azir APEC cũng có có sẵn mà Cho tôi xem
hàm răng và random Dạo này và ông có thể
truyền Min và mắc vào nó để nó xảy ra
rồi con số nó hợp lý hơn cái kiểu giá số
kiểu này nó sẽ bị ta thử hứa không Không
hẳn là ngon lắm không ạ Em đừng có lạm
dụng Face cơ quá
sinh ra khá nhiều đấy khá nhiều có truy
vấn vào thằng này
Ừ thế là hồi trước tôi khuyên mày ông
không dùng fastory không trường hợp đấy
mà cái tạo hạn à cứ lấy hẳn
Costa tổng cộng người trung toàn bộ danh
sách ID của Costa một lần ở trong cái
sít đâu ấy sau đó thì mình sẽ random cài
cái danh sách đấy thôi chứ không phải cứ
mỗi lần nha Cứ mỗi lần này ra tù lại cái
Coast khá nhiều nó sẽ bị nặng không ạ à
trong trường hợp này à
Ừ ok
à à
ừ ừ
cái này rồi thức ăn
Ừ mình cũng bày đặt nó bờ bwin sổ thấy
cơ thể gà hàng random number của thằng
TP có rồi đúng ạ làm hết rồi
Ừ ok tiếp nhằm tiếp theo 59 nhỉ
máy bay asiana
Em chưa có máy Vision
đã có sẵn của nó chứ gì cả ngắm 9 giờ
chưa gì cả
U50 vậy
ờ ờ
ở Điện Biên Hòa mọi sức khỏe đâu ạ
sữa tắm dê Delete vẫn chưa gì mấy
Ừ từ đinh
Anh cũng thế
cho các pan kte chẳng hiểu cái gì cả Ok
Ô rồi
anh yêu tôi khuyên Thì cái này nó bị dài
quá Thực ra tới thằng dúm kiểu thế người
ta mới ông thích cái ông với xóa thì tổ
ghi như cái kiểu này nữa mà đáy điểm cho
thích của cái việc tạo ô check rồi đẩy
xuống dòng trợ gửi hàng cho trông dễ
nhìn hơn
ừ ừ
khi con gì nhỉ
ô thưa bạn này mới chỉ làm thêm sửa xóa
cơ bản chẳng có gì nói cả
sản xuất Ê mèo nhóm 13
Âm Nhạc
em bớt date before Today cũng được tạm
như này có thể về sau nếu một kỹ càng
hơn thì mình sẽ có thể so sánh như có là
18 tuổi được ạ bằng cách thần kỳ đó thôi
kệ không sao cũng không cần khắt khe để
lắm chứ file lên
Ừ rồi
cơ bản cũng chẳng nói gì nhỉ
Ừ ừ
lấy cái này trở các bạn hết thôi à à
ừ ừ
e56 cập nhật bài nhà phút chưa
qua Xem cốt bài đang làm giỗ thì nó sẽ
như thế nào
Ở Bắc Kinh doanh solo đang làm phó kinh
luôn được sự thật
Ừ cái kinas
thế hả Sao chưa gì đã có cả bưu thủng
khiển thì tất cả bưu rồi
ông ấy không dùng vi format nhưng có chữ
thật
nên là mình nên dùng i5
Ừ để đánh số dễ hiểu - 23 gì đó mình sẽ
khó hiểu Nếu gửi thôi khó hiểu mình có
thể lưu lại trong dp là gì tùy theo mình
nên dùng 5 đoạn này
à à
hãy đoạn anh như tôi bảo ấy xuống dòng
rồi thì nó dễ hơn à
Ừ Ok cậu bị
số như ông cứ bị cho Thành và Thành
chuỗi không nên để nó số thì nó hợp lý
hơn thỉnh thoảng Vì sao nó sẽ lỗi đấy
nếu mà ông kiểu cứ để nó Trỗi bị số gì
đấy Xong chưa ở ngoài chạy rồi cái
có size bằng 2
ở đoạn này Thực ra như tôi đã bảo là
đoạn này thì ông hoàn toàn có thể là tạo
một cái Scope
101 escort để mà lấy ra được à
kiểu ví dụ là
ghét à Tên đấy sẽ là ghét à
thấy ông chỉ muốn 11,72 11 gì đó phía
sau rồi trở lại giống thể hot cốt theo
cậu là mình sẽ tạo một cái Scope hẳn tên
là Phó Đức Phương Trinh spa
chị
sẽ là thường tôi thương em chữ Peter
Peter size 11 chẳng ạ là xử thế esprit
đây hoặc quy lại tùy nó sẽ Return là quy
y xong rồi Where rồi đúng không ạ sau đó
thì 11 rồi đây ở đâu Cái này của ông ấy
là i Nam đúng không thì tôi sẽ đặt tên
nó lấy 5 cái gọi là thích
sai
rồi họ đến là 11 chẳng hạn
nếu như không được pháp để ở số rồi nha
chị sẽ là à
a big size
pc10 để số được thì nó sẽ lại F11 đi làm
thế thôi Cái này sẽ là 2
một kiểu ngay sau đó thì ở đây mình sẽ
sửa lại đây là Peter
có size 11
sẽ gọi thằng đấy cái hàm này
ở đây về sau thích cái ông chủ ông sửa
cốt ở trong này hả ông dùng lại những
cái đấy ở mọi chỗ khác được phải vì em
có phải quay nhà liên tục
ô ô thereby như thế này thời ta có một
cách giữa là Hai để mà ông thể làm tắt
từ cái Lọ này Thứ nhất là ông thể cái ở
đây ông sẽ xóa được đoạn này đi này và
nếu mà ông làm một kỹ hơn thì ông sẽ
lasted ở nhà hay sẽ là gọi nó sẽ mặc
định ở lại Theo cô thà dễ thật và sẽ lấy
theo thằng nặng lên nhất lại là xong cốt
trông ngắn hơn nhiều đúng không ạ
hiểu theo quy tắc thế thôi
ăn gì chưa em à
chị xem cỗ máy rồi còn cái gì với chị
nữa à
a snack sao thì không cần phải đi ở đây
đâu Thiếu cái que gì đây để nó sẽ gợi
thường tôi ghi quay ở đây thưởng để
thằng này đỡ tình báo vì sau nó sẽ gợi ý
mấy cái cái áo dưới nữa cho mấy ông đặc
biệt là liên quan đến mấy cái cậu Scott
như này nó sẽ gợi ý em ạ
Nhớ ngủ sớm nha
10 đặc trưng biến ở đâu ạ đủ là a này có
rồi đó nha
Ừ ông ấy Ông này à Ghét có để mà
anh không Nếu thế thì mình sống hằng thử
cao đi như này thì đỡ hơn mà không ạ sẽ
tìm việc và đây sẽ là biến trách axit
mạnh hoặc check đây mình sẽ check là ờ
quan đến
dung đoạn này của ông đấy là đang thêm
mới một cái sân và kiểm tra xem là
I seen to hơn cha nó có kiểu
Em thuộc ngày không nhưng mà không lấy
size của cái thằng mà mình đang mình
đang làm gì Mình hỏi kiểm tra sai chứ
nhỉ
ô hay mặc định là có người cha thì sai
anh sẽ là là bé rồi em nghe nói chung là
đoạn này thì tôi sẽ cứ giả sử là ông ấy
làm đúng đoạn này sẽ check à mình sẽ là
tên một cái trách và chiếc gì nhỉ
check à
à à
xe Jeep đúng không vẫn thường ấy giúp
này
à à
full về đây đây nữa
vì cậu ngày nào cho đơn giản cao
ở
đây ông mặc định quy ước nó là bốn cho
thơ ca là ông hoàn toàn Tôi nghĩ đoạn
này thì xử lý cho nó hợp lý hơn hợp lý
hơn đấy thì
thường là sẽ tạo một cái file hết ở đây
để trách
chú chó hợp lý nhất đây hack full o
phụ trách các andris2 cái gì đó Có chức
full kít chẳng ạ ạ
Ừ ông đặt ạ
chị cũng sẽ vứt cái hạn này ở đây như
này
cách so sánh với số 4 như ông vừa là
không ạ
ông sẽ chỉ cần
anh có đến hàng đô la gi I
ở nhà chơi fulla đóng kiểm tra xem nó
hợp lệ hay không Nếu giờ xử nó phun rồi
Như này chẳng hạn thì nó sẽ báo lỗi Còn
không thì chẳng sao cả Ghé Sao
a a truyền paste ID vào đây nữa
Ồ vậy hả
xong này Ok chưa
ở đó chỉ cốt ông sẽ ngắn hơn vì cái đoạn
này vì cơ bản đoạn này nên lôgic ở trong
file này gần như chủ yếu liên quan đến
việc là lưu lại chứ không nên làm thêm
cái một cái gì khác tự nhiên mình vẫn có
trách chủ nhưng mà nên những cái cốt xử
lý lô gích nên nằm ở những cái hàm nhỏ
hơn và đậm chất Sao mày biết đâu về sau
thể gọi chỗ khác nữa cho nên thế bởi vì
có bên apdate thì nó gọi đến thằng Hà
mày đấy nhá kiểu gì cũng phải kiểm tra
Chắc lại mà đúng không Giờ xử thế đấy
Ừ Ok chưa
ừ ừ
du lịch xe khách
anh chưa có gì cả Ok bỏ qua 19 nhóm nào
mà cần tôi chữa kỹ hơn thì nhắn tin
riêng sau nhé Mấy cái kiểu phân tích các
thủ Hử về cái này bao nhiêu buổi thôi tự
chữa hôm trước tôi nói rồi mình cái này
thì tôi sẽ chữa cụ thể sau
em à không có chữa mấy buổi hôm trước
rồi nên thành ra là bây giờ tôi sẽ dùng
chữa khẩu công khai rồi dạng để cho các
bạn cùng xem nữa mà vợ tôi bắt đầu từ
bây giờ tôi chán cốt được nhiều hơn tôi
không trở về cái xô thể các thứ thứ nữa
tốn hơn nhiều từ nhiều chữa sổ thể
rồi nên nhóm nào cần thì tôi sẽ nhắn tin
cho tôi tôi sẽ chữa riêng sao nếu hiểu
cho ông ạ thì cũng đỡ làm phiền đỡ làm
mấy ông kia cậu làm Qua phần đấy rồi Nếu
mày không cần để xem nữa không ạ
nhờ code của mấy ông ở tôi cũng sửa vài
cái mấy ông cũng hiểu hiểu hơn màn không
ạ tớ nghĩa ổn Đấy
kia
a520
em mới vẫn chỉ là thêm thật sáng thôi
tách nhỏ ra được cái đoạn liên quan lưu
này nó dài dòng quá đâu không thể tách
nó một phương trình nữa cũng được
anh cứ nhỏ nhỏ dần thế về sau mình dễ
quản lý mà về sau mình thích sửa đoạn mà
đại là ra xử với sao mình muốn sửa lại
cái tên tên cái lôgic để mà để mà cậu
Lưu lại sai thì âm sửa chỗ ở một hàm
thôi
anh nói chung Hà cái làm theo cậu làm à
lập trình chuyên sâu của này nó điểm hay
thế Có lẽ chuyện nhỏ nhỏ ra sau đó thì
ông sửa dễ hơn
không ạ
ở một cơ sở thích sao chợp
biết dùng tròn lắm đoạn này mình đây này
dùng về ship
ok
Vì thế nên là thôi không đúng đã ta thấy
bộ nữa cũng được Tôi chỉ khuyên mày ông
gặp nhau để tham khảo thôi chứ nếu bị
dùng da tay bổ hiểu ông ấy Mất đi cái
lợi của mình ship
thử đúng
I get array in fun
hai mẹ con quay này
à Ừ giờ thật lại làm cái này em
anh không Không ai làm cái này cả
Ồ vãi chưởng ai chỉ không Này đoạn này
làm dạo này vất vả thế
đi Hu hu cần bạn làm phức tạp phải đâu
đâu stallman này em ăn rồi lấy ngày
tháng hiện tại của Hồng swiss đây à
Đây là lấy từ cái này ra đúng không có
hàm để lấy được ngày cụ thể là men đây
Cái gì đó là mà không cần phải cậu con
với cửa nhà đâu
vậy chưa
chứ không phải xếp lại ạ Nếu lại sẽ cười
buồn rồi đấy thì vỡ mồm định lưu scandal
nhiều đâu nha skardu cả năm mới nhiều
nhưng mà lắm chị ạ ạ
Ừ dạo này à
ý nghĩa đoạn này nên xử lý có khác
sau nha
à Hôm nay tôi chưa có thời gian để ngồi
riêng cho một nhóm cụ thể thôi hôm sau
thích khi đó hôm sau nhóm này đi nhóm
mày rồi Mày cứ ngồi nghĩ lại cũng được
Nếu mà chưa được thì để thứ bảy lần sau
thích thì tôi sẽ chữa riêng cho một vài
nhóm cốt Hằng luôn kiểu để demo hàm luôn
những nhà máy ông nên có mấy ông lên đầy
á Shiseido lẫn cả Nói chung mai về Xem
các thứ lên để có sẵn nó bay rồi có sẵn
cái nên nó bay rồi tôi sẽ thử cốc cho
mấy ông thử mình cái đoạn này để hoa cà
rồng Ender dùng cái gì đó được để tôi
vào thằng máy mấy ông thì tôi sẽ có cử
cho mấy ông xem cái đoạn này thì nó lên
xử lý Mày toàn như thế nào chứ đoạn này
tôi thấy ông tự đây ra cốt của ông đoạn
này chồng có chứa nhiều không
anh hả bài thuốc này chuyên nghiệp ở đây
Dạo này chồng chưa buồn cười buồn cười
không ạ
hàng thì nó vẫn chạy là ngon rồi còn anh
em mình nhìn được cốt thì
chơi nhau thôi vẫn cái hàng đi tí nha nó
chạy được Tao đang ra cao hiểu không ở
đấy à
Safari đấy
Anh quay dùng để cho Thế ông ấy không
dùng quê xin ship ạ bởi vì bị kiểu lạm
dụng cài bên
ta thì bộ nhiều quá nghe rằng ship có
nhiều cái hay cái nó sẽ thấy là nó còn
viết hộ à Cái ngon ở điểm điểm ở đây
nhất ấy tôi thấy đó là khi mà không đổi
sang cái cơ sở dữ liệu khác thì cái cái
nó không bị sai mấy vẫn giữ nguyên được
Còn boy ở ví dụ nhảy sang nâu ashworth
trước đàn ông Lỗ mồm luôn rồi vì mình
roi trở lại thế lại còn bên ship của nó
vẫn dùng được nha vẫn dùng ngon có thể
dự Khi mà nhảy ý sáng cái nên tạng là
tao mấy khác chứ không phải tự nhiên
thằng Eriol Nó có sinh ra cái ghi ship
cho vui đâu tôi thấy thằng ship mà Ổn
thật nhớ Đương nhiên trong một vài
trường hợp nếu mà dữ liệu nặng quá thì
ông nên dùng doi thay ship gửi tiền nó
vẫn hay câu truy vấn ạ Không ạ nhưng mà
dữ liệu của mấy ông trên nỗi kinh khủng
đến thế không ông nên làm quen với bên
dùng chip tôi vẫn hướng đến cho mấy ông
là làm theo ở lâu quần xì líp để tận
dụng những cái điểm mạnh của thằng ngao
còn về sau để tối ưu khi ông thậm chí ở
Về sau phải cốt thuần vài chỗ vì nó quá
nặng trả nợ cái đấy tính sau
ở HK baby i
đi
mà tại sao có cái academy Liên minori
này rồi mày Ông về làm kiểu này thật là
không Cái về cái trả về nên cái xử lý
HTML lên ở bên file không nên để bác
ghen thì mình trong buồn cười
Xin lỗi tôi lỗi tôi xử lý cái này ở bên
nhé Tí nữa
ở giữa HTML
a fire fail fail đạo này lên con trai
cát
ông bác ông này đang dùng cái bác ông bị
lạm dụng về bác quá 3 thực à bác nó quay
trở lại nó không nó đôi khi nó lấy lại
cả cái á nó sẽ tự động điền lại cả cái
phone cũ không nên dùng bác mà phải Huy
đích cái hợp với bác nó sẽ bản chất là
điều hướng chứ
xe điều hướng nó khác với được bà
bấm nút quay lại nhé Nếu mà phân biệt
nhé Nếu mà bấm nút này nó quay lại nó là
đúng cái bát con Nếu mà giải ra sửa lấy
cái lưng dẫn của cái thằng cũ sau đó
điều hướng thì quay trở lại nó nó khác
nữa đấy nhé để phải video hack pass chứ
không phải bác như thế này đâu 03 sẽ vui
đâu nhé
định được mới gì cả nhưng nói chung này
Thực tế là bây giờ có nhiều bạn còn đang
bắt đầu từ đoán một chỉ các bạn thì làm
này cứ làm xong rồi Có gì khó thì vẫn
nhỉ inbox hỏi tôi hỏi riêng tôi tôi vẫn
sẽ hỗ trợ chấm Và thậm chí đã bảo vệ sẽ
bảo vệ rồi bảo vệ một mình bảo vệ riêng
thôi Nên là nên là kiểu
Ừ ừ đúng nhớ bạn cứ bảo là thực ra Tầm
tháng nào động tháng 8 đổ đi đến cuối
năm thì họ khá bận bạn thôi nhưng mà nói
chung là giúp đỡ rồi lúc nào sẽ tranh
thủ giúp đỡ được Đúng là trong thời gian
này thì vẫn sẽ ổn nhất thời gian này tôi
còn thoải mái trong mấy ông nhất bà làm
theo cùng các bạn thì nó sẽ gấu sẽ thoại
sẽ hiểu tâm lý anh em cùng cùng nhau đi
lên đúng không ạ Chị sẽ ổn hơn
Ừ nhưng mà vài người thì bây giờ không
bắt đầu được thì nói chung có về sau sẽ
cũng có tí thiệt thòi cho bảo anh em gọi
là khóa đầu này thì sẽ thuận lợi hợp
nhất đúng không ạ Vì sao anh em gần như
à anh em nào thích thì theo thôi chứ
anh không tinh thần bằng anh em khóa đầu
được đi em tháo đầu nhiều thì chuyện hơn
mẹ mày đi xăm làm mà I will
mẹ kể bé mày cũng làm nó diện
ở đây sơ sinh
à à
đẹp không có tâm
à Vì Sao Đưa nhà tôi sẽ đánh giá giao
diện về việc là cái Menu hay các thứ thứ
về cái lâu là cái tiến trình sẽ mà có dễ
hiểu dễ tường minh hay không thì tôi
không có tâm giao diện xấu hay đẹp với
các bạn thì mấy ông lấy sự giao diện về
rồi mà
em rất sex season
cơ hội lưu lại mỗi nêm trong đề không
lưu lại nữa rồi à
16 tau Ừ hôm qua âu cho bữa tối năng lỗi
vợ xóa
cho anh đăng ký á Không là mới có chuyện
đăng ký
các bạn muốn làm bác sĩ bên tôi không
không không có đăng ký đâu nhá
Ừ chị sẽ có amin thêm vào không đăng ký
đấy cả
ex0 đăng ký nha
la la không cần phải Johnson ở đây đâu
Mình chắc là cái này nếu mày lưu lại lỗi
thì nó điều hướng A thì mình thông báo
lỗi đừng quay lại thôi chai cá thôi chứ
address in your và kiểu ông làm xử lý
với nhiều bảng cùng một lúc thì ông kiểu
cần chơi dưới sân này mà
để mà nếu là sự có một cái lỗi vấn đề gì
khôi phục lại toàn bộ Mỹ những người bạn
kia chứ bản chất là cái này mà lưu lại
lỗi thì nó không đi lại trong B không
cần được rất sân của ngài
ừ ừ
phim update server Data Table CRD như
thời gian cập nhật mỗi người lao
xe
lửa rõ ràng là lừa
nên đem Tao thấy bồ sẽ ở đây vẫn cập
nhật mỗi lao
lễ hội lửa rồi
em không cắt đùi tôi
ha ha
ở Mỹ
Ê mày gửi lại á Đánh giá
à à
em chỉ mới ship COD không
Ừ ừ cũng với chị có xe đô rê cơ bản
Ừ vậy sao này rồi
xe đua tôi đúng không special
ở đâu Làm gì khó
anh alo rồi
ờ ờ
đúng không
Ừ
cái cập nhật
khi export Excel ra khẩu dùng cái thư
viện á thôi Cái đấy thì quan trọng gì
không Không quan tâm cái đấy
bộ set up Scream 2
để làm gì
Ừ ok
à à để cậu nè Ôi đi hẳn hót Quốc ở đây
luôn Ông còn bị đặt nó không truyền được
con choi năm thôi đi đây đã
ở đây luôn được mà Vào đây sẽ để fired
at five nhé
dùng hàm feel thì sẽ ngồi gõ lại hết rồi
gọi là biết cũng được
em heo
ê ê
anh cũng Download ông ấy có biết cách sử
dụng các thử này rồi nó
I Got A Boy ông ấy nhìn export Excel như
này nó uy tín hơn người ông kia xe lửa
trong ao nhà
đúng không để đăng ký đúng không lại
quay lại đăng nhập à Đăng nhập xong rồi
mình đi lại ao á Ừ cũng được nghỉ đâu
đăng nghiệp ông lưu áo kiểu gì
anh nhiều đấy à
rồi nhá Hôm nay t nói xấu sếp ở đâu là
tên hđxx sâu nhé Không hiểu giờ xong rồi
xếp nhà em nhé Không không không phải
làm này cả mà nên kiểu thế nên tách hẳn
một cái là Juan Angelo chứ không nên
kiểu ngày hôm nay cục chung ở trong News
cần cho lời
xem máy nghiền
các bạn hôm nay
em có bạn bảo xanh được bé
e-business firm
ừ ừ
Thật ra tôi vẫn khuyên là thích không
nên dùng kéo này mà nên dùng kéo dài
xuống dòng cái đấy nó sẽ lý hơn
ở ngoài dùng thiểu kết hợp cả bikini và
catalase
tôi vẫn không khuyên tôi không thích mày
ông dùng đất coi không dùng kiểu trò chứ
Chụp đã từng thử lắm nó kệ
Ừ cái này nên Tống những câu chuyện vẫn
dài như này như tôi bảo nên Tống nó sang
bên mua đồ chứ không nên kiểu ghi đầy đủ
tên này đúng ạ Đi ngắn gọn thôi
Ừ tôi lửa thích nữa không you the
weather thường anh tưởng như để trong
protel phải khai báo đây thì nó vẫn được
vẫn được thôi Nhưng mà không thích kiểu
này lắm
cô giáo sư Paris của người Nga
có làm gì đâu
anh không đặt tên file của anh nhá linh
tinh tôi hướng dẫn nếu đặt tên file chứa
nhé
a tinh tinh Kể tên file này sẽ là update
page không ạ viết liền
ở
trên này đem đi Tại sao tự nhiên của
Paris trên này nghỉ
trên là cái
Anh hiểu về tên Facebook trên
Số này của ông ấy lắm
họ và tên file này không em tình
thấy trên vãi chưởng
Ừ rồi còn cầu cách giấy đã
a a có cái đoạn dưới đấy à
à à
đã mở
Ừ Ông buồn cười nữa chưa
anh Dậy chỉ có mấy ông rồi mấy cái cây
dưới đây Alo
Ừ rồi
anh xex your skin chiều cao
3000 một không phải là thế này cả
anh không ai muốn so sánh kiểu như này
cả
em được về hôm sau tôi dậy chưa ông đã
này
kiểm tra để mở đứng yên để lấy ra là
check in đã chạy cao có sự thứ nhưng mà
lấy ra một lần thôi một lần thôi Không
phải kiểu sau đó thì mình sẽ
em lấy theo từng thần Androi lấy ra một
lần thôi Sợ nó dán vào chứ không phải
cậu như này vui rồi Ông bữa nay Câu truy
vấn thì chết à Đang tương đương gần này
vòng lặp mà phòng lập rồi từng thằng em
lo đi Đấy mai vợ rồi không ít hoài còn
như này nữa
Thế hả Tại sao có tham cao đấy nhỉ Sao
tự nhiên của tao đấy
I get này cao
hiểu lắm
hơi nhiều đấy không ra không nè
tôi phải chữa rồi
anh không xem nữa không đau mắt quá mất
tôi
Anh tên của cái mô đội Nga sửa sửa sửa
sửa không có bắt buộc phải sửa luôn
không ai chấp nhận chào kiểu đặt tên
file có thử như thế Bây giờ
ở đây Trời ơi tôi đi xem phim với nhớ
nhá Sửa sửa nhanh luôn Ở ngay không được
lập đi xe lại trong bụng lại được tôi
thấy cốt Vừa rồi ông say bin xe lại được
nha
em nói chào mày không nhé buồn
Ồ vãi cả chưởng